what's up everybody it's warren and
today
i don't really want to do my intro
because my guest is so good at intro so
i'm going to introduce supes and let him
do an intro
for episode 2 of my podcast soups take
it away what's up guys welcome back to
the wonder dome
me and cosmic warren are here to talk
about marvel
all of the crazy things that are going
down in one division and in spider-man 3
and so much is going down but me and
warren are ready to
discuss and break down all of it if you
guys don't know me my name is supes
i have my own youtube channel i'm mainly
known for my superhero content over
there on tick tock and instagram
but now me and warren are coming back
and collaborating
so long
300 subscribers i hit up warren he
reached back
and we hopped on to do something just
like this and now everything has come
full circle
and we're ready to come back and talk
about some more marvel stuff
yeah we are guys i like to have people
on
my podcast my channel that are different
than me but are in the same
kind of category so guys go check supes
out he's almost at 100 000 subscribers
help
him get there he's awesome he has
awesome content
he deserves to subscribe so
as he said one division we got a new
trailer recently for that
it was really cool and i mean just we
can't stop talking about spider-man 3
obviously i mean even right as we're
getting on to record this
there's news that willem dafoe and sam
are going to come back right
it's it's just crazy it's like almost
every other day there's something right
and now with the investor day giving us
a bunch of new marvel content there's
just something to talk about every day
so we're gonna dive into one division
first because there's some key parts of
the trailer
that are worth talking about for sure
now during the trailer there's a part
where
the radio goes off wanda and vision are
kind of starting to realize like the
reality is kind of
warping it may not be what they seem
which we know is going to happen
and the person on the radio says wanda
who is doing this to you
and then we see agnes who we know is
zagat the harkness
yeah she says can you help me can you
help us
what do you think is going on here supes
so
i think you know when the series starts
and wanda is in
just this fake alternate reality i think
she doesn't even know she's in a fake
alternate reality
i think she had her mind wiped and again
kevin feige said going into the series
that they're going to deal with the
mental health of wanda because she
suffered so much in the mcu
so because she suffered so much maybe by
her having agatha wipe her memory
maybe it cures her from experiencing
that pain that she holds inside
so i think she doesn't know what's going
on
and again because things are slowly
starting to transfer over into like the
real world
i think she's being alarmed and certain
things are going off here and there
that are triggering her memory like that
radio
trigger triggering her memory so like
that she can realize
what's really going on in all this right
and you know that's kind of taking it i
like that
take because that's taking it straight
from the comics because
you know when wanda has her kids and she
figures out they're the shards of
mephisto
and she's going kind of crazy right uh
agatha kind of does that she wipes her
memory of her kids
but then she slowly starts to remember
them and that's when you kind of get the
house of m storyline
which we know because kevin feige
already yeah basically
influencing the show right exactly so i
mean that could be spot on man i
i really think that and what other
reason do you really have agatha there
why is she in the fake reality right
because we know she's in actual reality
but why is she also there in the fake
reality
right um so i'm gonna add on top of that
because we have uh
tuna paris coming in right as rambo
yeah and she's in the fake reality too
but we know that she's also going to be
in actual reality she's in
real life and we know that we'll call
him sword
because we're pretty much convinced that
it's sword at this point right we'll
call him sword and we
we know that they're going to be outside
of this reality so it's like
whoever is doing this right and we'll go
with your theory because i like it a lot
agatha's doing this it's set in some
kind of bubble
in that town right so swords on the
outside
and i think that that's actually them
reaching through trying to get through
somehow they've somehow managed to send
monica rambo in there right and she gets
shot out because we've seen that part
right
and perhaps it's not wanda who shoots
her out perhaps it's agatha
yeah she's like you're not supposed to
be in here and she gets her out of here
right she's trying to do her own thing
with wanda
but here's my big question to you do you
think i get the
two-part question you think agatha is
good or bad
and do you think she's working for
mephisto
i think agatha is definitely bad okay
she is the bad guy in all of this
and i do think mephisto will definitely
be involved with doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
yeah i don't know if she's necessarily
working for him
she might just be kind of like a mortal
figure where mordo's still going to be
involved with doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
but i feel we all know that mortals kind
of on his own journey
on his own game plan right i think
agatha is in the same spot she's on our
own game plan
she could again she i could be wrong she
could be working for me fisto
but i think she's just putting out one
the strings here and she's just taking
wanda the most powerful character in the
mcu and she's just manipulating her and
putting her at a weak point
but also at the same time tapping into
her true potential
because this doesn't really seem like an
alternate reality per se
it seems like wanda just took over a
town and
took it over and made it exactly how she
wants it right
so all of this crazy stuff that's going
on in the wonder mission it's building
towards something and it's building
towards someone
so i think this all leads to mephisto
but i don't
know if agatha necessarily is working
for mephisto at this point in time
gotcha you think it's just going to be
just like you know cmg it's all
connected somehow
yeah right so it'll just lead into each
other so i agree with you i think
mephisto is definitely
maybe our next big villain well actually
i mean king's confirmed right there's
gonna be so many big villains coming up
but in the loki trailer that we got in
one of the scenes there's that like
stained mural in the back and you can
see
it's like satan so it's like that's
gotta be
mephisto right i mean because it's like
what are you gonna say it's satan
in the tva randomly like it's it's gotta
be mephisto so i think you're right
i think definitely more involved with
multiverse of madness because that's a
doctor strange villain
he's got a lot of ties with him and he's
got a lot of ties to doctor doom too but
that's like a whole nother tangent that
we could get off of
that um but it's funny because agatha in
the comics
is she's been good and bad right
she takes care of franklin richards
probably the most powerful mutant in
entire marvel history um the son
of reed richards and sue storm
mr fantastic and the invisible woman and
she does like their
job yeah they're coming right so it's
like this is kind of lining up maybe a
little bit more
maybe agatha kind of does a turn because
you're right she's
absolutely helping wanna develop her
powers more because she is set within
this reality but one is also shaping the
reality
right and we know that agatha is going
to be a huge part because she's the
nosy neighbor as they call her right so
she's gonna be over all the time
and she's gonna be influencing things as
we know so i think you're right on that
i think i think there's a really good
chance that agatha trapped her inside of
there
maybe wiped her memory before but i
definitely think agatha is the one who's
gonna help her further develop her
powers
and as kevin feige said we're going to
see her become the actual scarlet witch
and i think it does lead to mephisto for
sure and look
just throwing this out there i think for
sure for a fact
because this leads one division leads
directly into doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
i think we will definitely see doctor
strange in this series and
i think we're potentially going to see
something go down between
between agatha and dr strange yeah
because with wanda putting up this whole
show taking over this whole village
where there's literally a dome around
the village that she's taken over
right you don't think dr strange the
master of the mystic arts
would show up for something like that
happening
and because it's so connected to the
multiverse and alternate realities right
he would definitely show up that that is
his job
so what if he shows up and then agatha
because she's such an experienced
powerful wizard she just she
beats doctor strain and then
it gets to the point where once wanda
starts gaining her memory back
she wanda has the power to beat agatha
she eventually beats agatha and that's
where
everything gets messed up and boom right
there doctor strange and wanda are
paired up
and it leads directly into in the
multiverse of madness i love that
i love that especially because i had the
same thought because um
in infinity war strange tells tony stark
what you know he's like what is your job
he's like protecting your reality
right and then in game we learned that
the infinity stones create what we
perceive
or what you know in the universe they
perceive as reality so stones are gone
and it's doctor strange's job to protect
reality
so just like you said there's some
there's some dome
over a town and clearly magic is
happening
you don't think doctor strange is gonna
know that clearly realities are warping
and i definitely think i would love for
strange to fight agatha because you're
right agatha's been around since the
salem witch trials
yeah at least she's old
right exactly there's no one that
strange has fought that has more
experience than her
right in the mcu yeah exactly so she
would definitely give him a run for his
money
definitely so yeah i hope we see that
and that speaks volumes on just how
powerful wanda is that she doesn't know
how to use her powers
but just because of her raw power she's
going to eventually be able to beat
agatha
and then down the line as she continues
to work with strange
we see her develop and actually become
scarlet
witch right yeah she's gonna be
she she's probably already the strongest
person
in the mcu but once she fully developed
develops her powers she's gonna be
insane like yeah dude
and that's why asking spells yeah chaos
magic and i think eventually that's why
you're gonna have to have
so many villains and then the big bad
galactus right because it's gonna be
like
well you have to have somebody that's
gonna give wanda a hard time
right just like thanos like you're gonna
have to have somebody that's gonna give
thor a hard time because otherwise it's
like you know
it's thor so but that brings me into our
spider-man 3 section here because
huge multiverse and doctor strange is
confirmed for it right and it's like
why is he there yeah he kind of knew
spider-man and infinity war right
he had that run-in with him on the ship
with tony stark but it's like
he died right after that sadly right
both of them did right so
yeah and it's been much time together i
don't think strange is coming in
as like oh stark died so i gotta take
care of the kid right no for sure
because he wasn't in far from home
and tony was dead it's just not like
strange strange doesn't want to be
watching for a child
yeah that's not what he wants to do so i
definitely think it's
hey i feel something or i know
something i'm aware because it's my job
to be aware of our universe in reality
something's happened right other parts
from other realities are coming into
mind
i got to figure it out oh wait there's a
spider-man but it's not the kid that i
knew
so what's happening that's what i
personally think it's gonna be something
like that right
what are your thoughts on this so i
think with doctor strange being involved
in spider-man 3 we know there's going to
be multiversal elements in spider-man 3.
of course it's obvious it's confirmed at
this point
but i think we're one go going to see
spider-man
go to doctor strange first okay because
again spider-man doesn't have anyone
else
he lost iron man he doesn't have any
other heroes that he's really connected
to
so i feel that spider-man's going to go
to another hero that he knows
lives in new york doctor strange and i
feel that he's going to go to doctor
strange
in order for doctor strange to clear
wipe everyone's memory of peter being
spider-man
right again we can't really move forward
with tom paul and spider-man with the
entire world knowing that he's peter
parker right so it's going to have to
get
resolved at some point and again in the
comics in the congress actually goes to
mephisto
yeah so they could they could switch
that up to where he goes to doctor
strange and
you know doctor strange wipes everyone's
memory and then the whole multiverse
journey starts
but again i think just coming off of
what you said
it's going to be very similar to that
something something along those lines
where strange
takes peter strange feels something and
then he contacts peter
because again strange wasn't connected
to the rest of the avengers really yeah
he was only connected to tony stark and
spider-man from of the from their
adventures in avengers infinity war
right and i don't want to say that dr
strange didn't respect tony because i
definitely think
he ended up respecting him oh for sure
especially after a sacrifice
and all that he did um i would say
he didn't care too much because that's
just that's strange before he was a
master of the mystic arts right
um that's what's cool about seeing his
growth throughout the mcu right the
selfish doctor who cared about
materialistic things et cetera et cetera
and now he's gonna help our boy out
right
but i like that because there actually
is another comic
where his peter's identity is revealed
and he goes to stark and stark
and mr fantastic go to strange and they
all decide
that strange should wipe everyone's
memory
um so we might get something like that
mephisto may prevent
present himself to peter parker i doubt
that'll happen because that's just
so much that could happen in the movie
um because one of the main things that
people are worried about right now it's
like well it's so much going on right
but it's like god
and to the spider birds did it really
really well there was a lot of
spider-man in that one but it was still
a miles morales story
exactly and that that's what i go back
to every single every time you know yeah
because as this cast continues to grow
and as they continue to throw so many
more people into this movie
everyone's getting more and more worried
but sony did
into the spider-verse where they
introduced a new spider-man in miles
morales
they also introduced an entire lineup of
new spider-man
and threw him through them in the movie
and then you also had the sinister six
in the same
movie right right and it was still very
much a miles morales
story so again in spider-man 3 yes
you're going to have
you know if the rumors are true you're
going to have tommy mcguire and andrew
garfield and all of these other
villains in the movie but tom holland's
spider-man is going to be at the heart
of it he's going to be the vehicle
that takes us throughout this crazy
journey the same way miles was that
vehicle for spider-man is the
spider-verse
yeah and you can do that while having
everybody else in
and let's be honest the second you
advertise
like they if they if it is a true
spider-verse film which it's like
99 it's yeah we're just waiting on an
official announcement
right exactly but they'd be
crazy not to announce that ahead of time
they'd be crazy not to show
the three spider-man together because
let's face it they do that
in previews it's gonna be the biggest
movie it might be in-game like it
probably will be
in-game dude we're getting this first
look this month i know
and i don't even think we need a trailer
all we need is
a 30-second video of tom holland walking
out talking about spider-man 3
and then he says something along the
lines of but i'm not alone in this one
right from his left right come toby
mcguire and andrew garfield
and that's all you need and the internet
is going to break break yeah earlier
oh yeah you want to get people back into
theaters bring together the three
spider-man bring back toby maguire bring
back andrew garfield
and people will show up for this movie
100
that is a guarantee you're a hundred
percent right
because and that's true and that's a
really good play if you want to get
people back in theaters
boom show it do and you don't even got
to show it right don't even
show footage you can literally show them
and then like you said just
you could show a picture honestly right
you could show a picture
and put the title on it but have three
spider-man on it and
everyone's gonna freak out the internet
breaks right we can't post on youtube
anymore because it's just too much
it's like everything's down tick tock
goes down everything's down
just because everyone freaks out about
it so
i'm very excited to see what we're gonna
get but tying it back in
so we know one division is gonna connect
to spider-man 3 and then spider-man 3 is
going to connect into doctor strange and
multiverse of madness
there was a report that came out from
fandom wire two days ago
or so said that tobin will guy is not
just going to be in spider-man 3 he's
going to go into
multiverse of madness as well what do
you think the key tying factor is
between one division
spider-man 3 and doctor strangers do we
think it's doctor strange because that
would make
sense what are your thoughts i think it
is doctor strange
because again he is the master of the
mystery this is his world
right where this is this is his arena
where this just
crazy game is being played right but
again i do
uh if the reports are true we're gonna
get toby
and the multiverse of madness and again
it makes sense because
spider-man 3 is already such a
jam-packed movie we're not gonna get to
see
much of toby and andrew if they are in
that movie
right so it would make sense for them to
just
transfer it over into multiverse of
madness right why not
i mean after after this entire crazy
journey is done we're not gonna get to
see tony maguire spider-man ever again
right yeah
one thing that really does excite me is
seeing sam raimi
back in the director's chair directing
toby mcguire spiderman
right and it's like how perfect is that
it's so perfect and
complete and you know he oh and they're
supposed to be a spiderman for a sam
raimi toby maguire spider-man 4.
exactly and he always said like i wish i
could have wrapped it up
it's perfect now and that's the
beautiful thing
that's the beautiful thing that now toby
can finally get his ending spider-man 3
wasn't an
ending because there was supposed to be
a four five and six yeah
now toby can get his ending where we can
say goodbye
to spider-man same thing with andrew
garfield spider-man
and i did nothing excites me more to be
able to see both of these men
return to this role because they hold
such a special place in all of our
hearts
oh yeah oh yeah seeing them come back
and finally getting the endings they
deserve
it's just gonna be phenomenal and i
think that's what they're doing because
if you think about it why is kristen
duns coming back
why is there a stone coming back yeah
right why are why are there love
interests coming back
you know the villains are coming back
and that's very very interesting
especially some that are dead i mean
gwen stacy's dead right but why are they
coming back i don't even care if they
retcon a little bit of it i mean don't
do too much right
yeah especially to the sam raymond one
but
i'm all for them getting their endings
i'm all for them getting their respect
especially andrew garfield because i
think he was a great spider-man
it's not his fault that people didn't
receive the movies very well
but he was a really good spider-man so i
think like putting the ending
giving them their ending at a really
good ending would be great
yeah look this is what i think is gonna
go down with andrew spiderman and i'm
the biggest andrew garfield fan in the
world
i know he's spiderman and seeing this
fan
come back to play this character because
that's what he is he's not an actor he's
a fan yeah i'm spiderman yeah
if you watch the interviews he just
understands spiderman the character
completely
so i'm just so happy to see andrew come
back and play this character that he
loves so much
but what i think is actually going to
happen is that when we see tom
or tom spidey go traveling out
throughout the multiverse
seeing these different versions of
spider-man i think he's going to enter
into certain points in history like what
if he enters
andrew garfield's universe during the
electro fight
and then before when stacey even dies so
then
spider-man could have that happy ending
where peter and gwen end up
have having their happily ever after and
that's how we cap off that story
that would be fantastic that'd be
amazing exactly what's
amazing what if he enters the raimi
universe
during the train sequence oh
molina is not dead at that point he's
not dead at that point too he comes
right after that right he helps him stop
the train exactly
and then we can get a different
perspective of one of the most iconic
spider-man scenes of all time the same
way
we got like the aftermath of the the
loki scene at the
end of avengers and or at the end of the
first avengers where they're confronting
loki
and then we got the prologue to that
innovation right right
yeah yeah yeah just a different
perspective yeah
i'm all for that i think that would be
fantastic and i think that would be
it's almost like um uh lion king
like 1.5 right where it's like you see
timon and pumbaa what they're doing
throughout the entire thing
which is what i really hope deadpool is
like they just showed deadpool in the
background for deadpool in the mcu it's
just like deadpool during infinity war
and end game
like because then you see like everybody
else but deadpool's just doing his own
thing that's like really what i want to
happen
but anyways i think it'll be fantastic
and i do think
retconning things like that as far as
the amazing spider-man goes
to where he helps him at the end and he
you know makes it to where gwen never
dies and then they get their happy
ending
and then the same thing it would be
really cool to see him
just in the rainbow universe right it
would just be phenomenal
and what's kind of cool about that point
that you make right there
is that that's not even necessarily
them in the mcu but tom in their
universe
right so it's super super cool and i
actually had a theory that maybe doctor
strange
while mentoring tony i'm sorry while
mentoring peter
um maybe go you know maybe peter's like
i can't do it's really hard blah blah
blah just kind of like that scene he had
with happy
and far from home and happy you know
encouraged him maybe strange goes
let me show you something and he goes
other universes and he says this is this
spider-man he had his trials
it goes to the other verse other
universe this is this spider-man he
certainly had his trials
they did it you could do it something
like that we don't really know it's
gonna be insane but i really like what
you said and i'm kind of hoping that
happens now
because that would be pretty insane i
mean it's iconic and it would explain
why we see emma stones gwen stacy in
this movie to give them
you know the ending that they should
have had but then right obviously when
stacey died
so it makes sense and i feel like that's
kind of like the perfect ending for
andrew spider-man since we're never
gonna win to get to revisit that ever
again right yeah
yeah and then to go back to that train
sequence which is the most iconic
spider-man scene of all time
it would get the fans buzzing it i all i
know is that
if they they do one of those transitions
where it's just like
new york 2004 and then you see the train
going
and then i know the fans
go insane absolutely insane yeah so just
like
when the avengers go back in time and
then you see new york yeah i
i get what you're saying yeah that would
be absolutely insane and
i'm torn because i like that idea so
much i'm torn between wanting that to
happen
and then them coming into our universe
right
well i think it's possible that he goes
to them
and then they come with him yeah i mean
that would be pretty great
it all builds up to something because if
they're bringing together the three
different spider-men
we're getting a fight with the three
different spiderman against all of these
crazy villains yeah i mean all of them
are coming right so it would only make
sense that
peter would need help you know and
especially if they bought them before
i mean obviously it's gonna be like well
i'll help you right and
if he goes in their universe and he
helps them with something if he saves
gwen
if he helps peter on the train right
then they're going to kind of feel like
they need to help this guy right i mean
and it's and it's themselves exactly
it's the multiverse the
snake right exactly you don't have a
choice they have to help them they have
to
right it's you know how crazy would it
just be
if you see if we cut to the sam raymond
universe and it's just toby
and then all of a sudden it's just like
um tony and infinity war
portal opens up strange walks out and
tom holland's right next to him dude
it's like peter parker i legit told my
friend about the same
thing like a parallel scene right where
it's like toby with you know his mj
and then he walks in and it's peter and
mj and then doc
you know tom spidey walks right strange
and doctor strange is like
peter parker the multiverse
is at stake here i know right oh and
then
and then that's where we got mary jane
right get him tiger
gold kind of tiger yeah i got it oh i
can't enough i get chills thinking about
it i know
and it's there's and it makes me feel
good that we have all these ideas
because we know marvel's thinking of all
this and they're gonna choose whatever
like the best option is
and and that's the beautiful thing about
endgame is that going into endgame we
had all these different theories
and then marvel took a mixture of our
theories
and com mixed it with stuff that we
didn't even think about
right that's exactly what we're they're
going to do with this movie they're
going to take
the theories we're already talking about
right now and then combine it with
things
we never even fathomed right so it's
gonna be insane man it's gonna be insane
and i
full trust in marvel they i
they haven't let us down right the mcu
hasn't let us down i mean
kevin feige is genius
i mean really and john furrow's a genius
just look at what he's done for star
wars
but he's been part of marvel since iron
man won since the very start of the mcu
executive producer and everything i have
full faith in them so whatever's going
to happen in this spider-verse film
i'm ready for or maybe i'm not ready for
it i don't know maybe it's just like so
big
that we can't even fathom what they're
gonna do yet and look that's the thing
that up to this point with tom holland's
spider-man movies which i haven't been a
fan of i haven't been
i haven't been i'm not a big fan of
homecoming and far from home but at this
point with tom hall in spider-man movies
sony has put the leash on marvel and
saying you could only have
this many characters in the film right
no you could only have this villain
you could only have this character in
this movie but
with this movie the leash is off yeah
sony is letting kevin feige
take all of the characters he wants from
any freaking universe
bringing back anyone and it feels like
they're giving kevin feige and the
people over at marvel
full yeah full responsibility and for
just
creative creative choices to be able to
take this film and make it
bigger than endgame because i think when
you bring just the idea of bringing back
three different generations of
spider-man in one movie
and then on top of that you're bringing
back the iconic villains that
push these spider-man to their limits
having that all be in one movie
that's going to rival avengers end game
yeah i'm sorry no it will
no i i fully agree with you especially
because i think
i think spider-man's such an iconic
superhero like i grew up watching
spider-man
yeah and reading the comics and i don't
know i feel like
kids it's like spider-man right uh you
know
it's not necessarily the avengers i mean
now right but when i was a kid because
i'm a little bit older he is that guy
right it was spider-man when i was
younger it was spider-man
right it wasn't the avengers it was
spider-man and x-men for me
because i had the x-men animated series
yeah but now since we got the mcu the
avengers are a really big deal iron
man's a really big deal he wasn't that
big of a deal in the comics but
spider-man was that person
everybody knows who spider-man is
everybody knows who's spider-man
character in the world
yeah and the thing is that he's the most
relatable
yes you know superman can be the most
popular for me superman's my favorite
superhero of all time
but for the masses who the masses
spider-man is the most relatable
character he's the kid
fighting alongside all of the adults
he's experiencing
adult issues and plowing through
these obstacles becoming the greatest
superhero of all time everyone loves
spider-man
and you know there's people that grew up
with toby maguire as their spider-man
right
there's people who grew to love andrew
garfield
as spider-man yep and then there's also
kids growing up today
loving tom hall and spider-man in the
mcu so you're bringing in
three different generations of fans yep
and that's and that's why it it has the
potential to be bigger than in game if
they
do it like that it will and just dude
like we haven't even seen any footage
and we're seeing all these reports and
all these casting announcements
are you kidding me are you kidding me
release release an official casting
sheet
of what this of the of the cast of this
film and just that alone
keeper a paper confirming all the
castings yep
that are going to be in this movie it
would you have the title up top
spider-man home sweet home whatever it
may be yeah and then below
cast tom holland toby maguire
to garfield into the cover back and and
that's all you need to do
you don't need a teaser you don't you
don't need footage you don't need a
picture that's the picture you need
is that that's brilliant and that's what
they should do and
doesn't require much work from them at
all either and that'll break the
internet
the second they confirm the multiverse
marvel actually confirms it the
internet's done so
good luck internet well this has been
awesome
soups thank you so much for joining me
this is like full circle
soup started when we first did our our
first
video together he had under a thousand
subscribers now he's almost at a hundred
thousand subscribers
he's got do you have two million on tick
tock yet we're about to hit two million
over there on this so close
two almost two million on tick tock
insane
blowing up on instagram tick tock
blowing up on youtube guys
head over to soups help them get to 100k
subs
any last thing any loss predictions
anything for spider-man 3.
so first of all bro i want to thank you
for having me on inviting me to come
have this conversation
had a wonderful time um and guys all i
have to say
in regards to marvel is to never count
marvel out
yeah after end game there were so many
people saying marvel's done
i know they should reboot they're never
coming back after they lost iron man and
captain america
and now look a year later here we are
right talking about something that could
rival or potentially
surpass avengers end game so never count
marvel out
2020 has been one hell of a year where
all of the things we've been looking
forward to have been getting delayed
but our time is coming our time is
coming
big time so thank you guys for having me
on make sure to go check me out on
youtube
instagram tick tock and i look forward
to seeing you guys on those platforms
awesome man thanks for joining us
everybody thanks for watching subscribe
to soups soups i'll let you
give them a woof woof to end it so
thank you guys for tuning in i hope we
hope you guys enjoyed
we'll see you guys next time
you